it was a huge stories remember NBC said
it would fix itself after the scan we'll
get to the bottom of what happened and
prevent it from happening again did they
do that
Linda Wester has been following this
very carefully ever since she's a
philanthropist a filmmaker and a former
network news anchor including here her
group is a full-page ad running in the
New York Times tomorrow morning also a
piece on the Fox news.com opinion
section
published just minutes ago which is
definitely worth reading Linda Wester
joins us Linda thanks very much for
coming on so one of the reasons I'm
grateful that you're bringing this to
public attention is that there was
supposed to be an investigation a public
investigation from which we could all
learn you know what happened and I sort
of wonder what where is it well they
published the results of this so-called
investigation but but the truth wasn't
in there because at least six women at
least six women who were victimized by
Matt Lauer this according to them
telling me personally or people close to
them confirming to me were never
interviewed and they had damaging
details about Lauer and about others in
management who allegedly protected them
nothing happened they weren't spoken to
properly that also means also there are
four members who are on air talent who
worked closely with Matt who were never
interviewed they too had important
information and I believed the network
knew it that that not only implicated
Matt but implicated other men in
positions of power at NBC News and that
never got investigated there has to be a
question about why that didn't get out
why did any lack the chairman of NBC
News not let this get out is it because
he himself has a history of reported
sexual misconduct in the workplace in
the past and so he himself is guilty or
is it because he just wanted to protect
him to protect other high-profile men at
the company he cares more about the
bottom line doesn't really care about
the women whose lives and careers and
reputations are being destroyed he just
cares about the money and the men he
wants to protect but this is part of NBC
as part of a large publicly traded
company comcast that's right and you
would think they would have an interest
in getting to the bottom of this
why haven't they it
is long overdue that the Comcast Board
of Directors get involved you're right
they are directors of a publicly traded
company they're answerable to
shareholders they are answerable to the
public this is a broadcaster that is
regulated by the FCC
so these Board of Directors they cannot
get away with burying their heads in the
sand these are real women whose lives
and careers and reputations are being
destroyed they can't ignore them Comcast
just put out a Twitter handle yesterday
that said Comcast cares well does it
really
the directors need to make it their
business get involved to investigate all
of the alleged predators and imitate
news
not just Matt Lauer not just Tom Brokaw
who assaulted and harassed me but the
many many others and they need to get to
the bottom of it they need to publish
the findings and they need to clean out
what's wrong at NBC News and really be a
beacon as a journalistic organization
should be you mentioned Andy lack who
runs it and suggested that he himself
ought to be investigated has he Biss and
and now do you think there's evidence
that that he ought to be the subject of
an investigation I know of two
particular victims of his both have been
interviewed by reporters and I know of a
member of CBS News management who was
involved in both of those cases who
confirmed that to me so yes that exists
and has also been in print I mean this
is out in the news and it's and what is
shocking to me is that it's easily
findable you could google this and does
NBC Universal and Comcast just not care
does Steve Burke and he lacks boss did
he know about this and just not care
that he had an alleged I would say
predator running the news division does
Brian Roberts not care what he was
founded as Comcast was founded as a
family company tell me how that is a
family company when women are being
abused and being silenced and these
non-disclosure agreements and and forced
arbitration are literally choking
they're very voices off and preventing
them from speaking how fair moral and
ethical is that this is a news
organization they should do much better
well the fact that Andy lack has been
accused
that who's running it is shocking can
you very quickly can you give us a sense
of the timeframe under those allegations
against any lack they were in the 80s I
am told by the people who are
knowledgeable about this and when he was
executive producer at West 57th it's a
just amazing story NBC ought to be
leading the charge to get to the truth
but they're not they said you are wind
investor thank you very much for that
thank you